[Musik]
ja wenn es am 17 märz wieder heißt
abstimmung lege ich meinen umschlag ganz
selbstverständlich in die uhr
dabei sind wir frauen in der schweiz
erst seit 50 jahren demokratisch gefragt
der kampf vom herd bis zum heute
erreichten war lang auf druck des
verbandes für frauenstimmrecht kommt es
von 1918 bis 1921 erstmals zur
kantonalen abstimmungen über das
stimmrecht für frauen in allen sechs
kantonen sagen die männer nein auch
später abstimmungen bleiben erfolglos
ende der 50er jahre beantragt der
bundesrat die einführung des
frauenstimmrechts das parlament stimmt
zu doch 69 prozent der männer sagen 1959
in der abstimmung nein nein so nicht
meinen die frauen
sie rufen zur fackelzügen auf sie werden
selbstbewusster 1969 der große marsch
der frauen nach bern eine unbewilligte
demonstration am rednerpult emilie
lieberherr
die schweizer männer werden wach
getrommelt schließlich die denkwürdige
abstimmung und der sieg 66 prozent der
männer sagen diesmal ja warum eigentlich
waren die frauen so bedrohlich und wen
wollen wir heute nicht mitreden lassen
über das offene projekt demokratie
spreche ich jetzt mit meinen drei gästen
und zwar ist bei uns fabienne am limes
ist historikerin am interdisziplinären
zentrum für geschlechterforschung an der
universität bern und bei uns zu gast ist
auch sie ja häusermann professorin am
institut für politikwissenschaften an
der universität zürich und zugeschaltet
aus berlin ist uns die historikerin
hätte die gerichte professorin an der
universität der bundeswehr münchen ganz
herzlich willkommen
ja frau richter in deutschland zwischen
die frauen seit 1918 in der politik mit
wie blickt man denn von deutschland aus
auf die schweiz eines der länder
eines der letzten länder europas dass
die frauen mit release also der blick
von deutschland auf die schweiz ist
glaube ich ein ganz typischer blick von
außen volle bewunderung wir bewundern
die schweiz weil das einfach dass länder
demokratie ist wurde schon ganz früh die
menschen wählen konnten und ich denke
das ist ganz ganz typisch für uns ein
blick auf demokratiegeschichte dass die
frauen einfach ausgeblendet werden das
ist dann so ein bisschen komisch dass
die frauen erst zu spät kam
aber wir verstehen eben und erzählen uns
demokratiegeschichte viel viel stärker
als wir uns dessen bewusst sind als eine
meiner geschichte
das ist ja interessant wie geht es ihnen
frau häuser machen wenn sie in
deutschland unterwegs sind an
konferenzen müssen sie jeweils die
schweiz verteidigen
nein das muss ich nicht ich wollte mal
botschafterin werden als mädchen dann
hätte ich das vielleicht tun müssen aber
als professorin muss ich auf alle länder
gleich und gleich kritisch schauen wenn
es um die gleichstellung in der schweiz
geht drängt sich so ein kritischer blick
natürlich auf tatsächlich ist das
wirklich eine eine diskrepanz zwischen
der sehr frühen einführung des männer
wahlrecht
das auch nicht für alle männer aber für
die meisten männer und dann wäre extrem
späten einführung des frauenstimmrechts
jetzt hat ja frau richter gerade gesagt
man bewundert eigentlich die schweiz die
schweiz wird ja oft auch zelebriert als
wiege der demokratie oder sie zelebriert
sich selbst aus wiege der demokratie
aber tatsächlich schlossen eben die
männer die frauen 120 jahre lang aus
also die hälfte der schweizer oder eben
die schweizerinnen kann man das wirklich
eine demokratie nennen wenn die hälfte
nicht mitbestimmen darf ja das ist eine
gute frage und sie geht natürlich genau
auf den titel dieser sendung also unter
das thema die versendung die oft auch
offene projekt demokratie
ich denke man muss man darf diese frühe
einführung des dass männer wahl und
stimmrecht es nicht entwerten das war
eine sehr wichtige entscheidung eine
sehr wichtige etappe der
demokratisierung
aber diese demokratie damals hat in
ihrem demos also in der gemeinschaft der
berechtigten natürlich diverse gruppen
ausgeschlossen die frauen ganz klar auch
die armen die verarmten die verurteilten
die konnten und erst über die zeit gab
es so wellen von von inklusion und ich
denke man muss schon gibt es hat nicht
sagen vor 71 war die schweiz keine
demokratie und nach 71 ist sie eine
demokratie so einfach ist es natürlich
nicht aber die einführung erst 19 71 ist
natürlich schon auch als auch wenn man
den kontext berücksichtigt so dieser
normalisierung einer demokratischen
expansion ist 71 extrem später auch im
internationalen deshalb schon ein sehr
großes demokratisches defizit natürlich
sie ist interessant was sie sagen also
auch betonen die schweizer gar nicht
sehr früh tatsächlich eben eine
demokratie ja sagt zum beispiel auch
flavia kleiner die politik aktivistin
die operation libero mitbegründet hat
sie betont in einem interview mit dem
kulturplatz auch dass es ja eigentlich
interessant ist schon so früh hat
eigentlich die schweiz aus europa
mitnimmt und eigentlich versunken ist
revolutionen kriegen die demokratie
eingeführt und dann ging es doch so
langsam sind die frauen ja nicht ohne
stimme gewesen vorher das betonen sie
frau am länger sie sagen die frau hatte
durchaus
was zu sagen einfach in einer sehr
anderen rolle nämlich auf sogenannte
stauffacher rinn wie sie das umreißen
wir sehen ein bild der staufach hin dass
auf dem rathaus in schwyz prangt und die
schaufeln ist ja die figur die frau
werner von stauffacher sagenumwobenen
kommt vor in wilhelm tell bei friedrich
schiller und ist einer der drei der die
eidgenossenschaft mitbegründet haben
soll
mit dieser staufach hinauf sich just in
diesem ursprung smid es zur entstehung
der eidgenossenschaft kommt eben diese
staufach in eine ganz zentrale rolle zu
und zwar gemäß dieser erzählung sei sie
gewesen
die idee nehmen also diesen wellen
stauffacher dazu ermutigt habe mit
gleichgesinnten eben diesen bund zu
schließen also die sage von südlich
kennen wir diese schuh mode ag tätig
wurde und letztlich der
eidgenossenschaft begründete und jetzt
kann eigentlich dieser geschichte
dahingehend interpretiert werden dass
bei diesen bund ja keine männer vor ort
waren aber die idee lässt sich von
dieser frau stammt also dass die frau
indirekt über ihren ehemann massivsten
politischen einfluss haben konnte und
diese figur der staufach liegt fand dann
auch eine entsprechung im modernen vun
der stad als 848 und die gewohnte stadt
konzentriert wurde auch das eigentlich
ein bunt unter gleichberechtigten männer
und kompletter ausschluss von frauen
aber auch da war dann plötzlich das
narrativ ja die frauen die können ja
indirekt über ihre ehemänner doch
politisch einfluss nehmen
ein stück weit ist dass sie dieses
narrativ ja auch geprägt worden dann in
diesen wahlkämpfen in diesen
abstimmungen später dass man gesagt hat
naja die frau die kann ja schon
irgendwie mitbestimmen wir brauchen dich
dieses neumodische zeugs mit so einem
richtigen wahl und stimmrecht oder diese
narrativ hat sich sofort gesetzt hat die
sehr lange durchgesetzt und zwar sowohl
bei denen die an die urne gingen aber
auch bis zu höchster politischer ebene
ja und das finde ich schon bemerkenswert
also selbst 1959 als es zu essen
abstimmung kam über sagen es ist
frauenstimmrecht da hat der bundesrat
zwar für ein ja votiert aber in seiner
botschaft hatte diese gut nochmals
angerufen als er hat auch nochmals
erwähnt
dass die frauen ja indirekt doch immer
schon politisch partizipieren könnte
konnte und ich finde das schon also
demokratietheoretisch eine
bemerkenswerte aussage in der zweiten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts frau
richtete sie haben ein buch
herausgegeben über frauenwahlrecht haben
sich lange zeit mit diesem thema
befassen zwar frauenwahlrecht eben über
länder vergleichens in ganz europa ist
dieses narrativ dass die frau ja
durchaus was zu sagen habt nicht nur am
herd sondern auch indirekt die kann ja
die männer so ein bisschen beeinflussen
doch das ja eigentlich ausreicht ist
dafür aktiv dass man in etlichen ländern
finde wenn alle länder haben sich die
frauen erst mal ausgeschlossen
ja das ist tatsächlich ein ganz
wichtiges argument
die frauen sind nicht schlecht aber sie
sind eben anders und deswegen sollte man
sie weil sie positiv auch anders hin
weil sie das bessere geschlechts und
deswegen sollte man sie nicht in diese
dreckige politik lassen das war
tatsächlich ein ganz starkes argument
und da ist ganz interessant dass viele
frauenrechtlerinnen dieses differenz
argument aufgenommen haben die meisten
um 1900 leben sehr sehr stark in dieser
vorstellung dass geschlechter
unterschiedlich sind und die haben dann
gesagt gerade weil wir anders sind
brauchen wir ein stimmrecht gerade weil
wir ein trick kompetenzen haben weil wir
für die bildung so stark zuständig sind
weil wir für hygiene damals ein
wichtiges feld zuständig sind gerade
deswegen brauchen wir das stimmrecht
dass es ganz interessant wie das
umgedreht wird
aber es ist überhaupt interessant welche
argumente alle in anschlag gebracht
wurden warum frauen nicht wählen dürfen
in frankreich beispielsweise war es
steigt dass die zu katholisch sind dass
die katholische kirche die frauen
verführt und dann eben immer wieder
dieses argument rein vom körper her sind
frauen anders und sollen deswegen weil
sie ein schwächeres gehirn haben weil
sie von ihrem körper von ihrem motto
russ geprägt sind deswegen sollen sie
unter keinen umständen in dieser
rationalen nüchternen welt der politik
mitmachen
nun ist sich aber trotzdem kann es
eindeutig so dass in der schweiz diese
negative noch sehr viel länger prägend
waren denn nun mal einfach die zahlen
anschauen ich habe schon erwähnt in
deutschland dürfen die frauen ab 1918
mitreden norwegen auf 19 13
großbritannien ab 19 28 frankreich 19 44
italien 19 45 jetzt mal von ihnen her
vergleichend geblickt warum denken sie
hat die schweiz so spät erst reagiert
das hat natürlich ganz ganz viele
ursachen das hängt damit zusammen dass
die mails direkt darüber abstimmen
müssen und wir wissen von vielen anderen
inklusions prozessen wenn es da
abstimmungen auf der in der basis gab
dass das dann besonders schwierig war
zum beispiel in den usa als die sklaven
befreit wurden mit dem ende des
bürgerkriegs 18 65 gab es viele viele
abstimmungen auf staaten ebene und haben
die männer immer auch in den nordstaaten
die eigentlich die sklaven befreit haben
immer gegen diese inklusion der der der
schwarzen gestimmt die sollten kein
stimmrecht haben
und es ist ganz interessant in vielen
demokratisierungsprozesse sehen wird es
dass demokratisierung nicht immer von
unten aus gehen muss sondern oft eben
auch von der bundesregierung oder von
bestimmten am eliten von liberalen
progressiven eliten befördert werden
das ist ein interessanter punkt frau
häusermann in der weltwoche hat ein
ökonom hans rentsch erst kürzlich
geschrieben
es gebe überhaupt keinen grund dass die
schweiz sich schämen müsste im gegenteil
die schweizer nämlich das einzige
demokratische land der welt das eben per
volksabstimmung den frauen dieses recht
zugestanden hat und wenn man in anderen
ländern
das volk hätte mitbestimmen lassen also
sprich alle männer dann hätten die bis
heute vielleicht auch kein
frauenstimmrecht stimmt das so ja
vielleicht das können wir natürlich
empirisch nicht überprüfen weil es weil
es eine ein szenario ist sicher die frau
richter gesagt hat ist es so dass diese
inklusions bewegungen in der regel von
den eliten ausgingen
und ich denke das liegt also dass das
hier die die volksabstimmung er eine
bremsende wirkung hat nicht nur bei den
frauen auch bei den frauen denke ich
liegt daran dass wenn diese inklusion
wirklich von der breiten bevölkerung
getragen werden muss setzt sie eben
voraus dass schon vor der inklusion oder
vor der ausweitung der politischen
rechte an ein umdenken ein neudenken der
quasi dessen was ein bürgerinnen
bürgerin ist was es dazu zu gehören
selbstbestimmt subjekt sein zu können in
der demokratie
dieses umdenken muss schon recht weit
fortgeschritten sein um dann eine
mehrheit zu gewinnen in der bevölkerung
während dem wenn natürlich die
entscheidung eher von oben kommt dann
durch die entscheidung selber ja auch
viel passiert durch die erfahrung die
dann gesammelt wird mit der veränderten
praxis also ich glaube einfach die die
geschwindigkeit mit der er dann diese
vorstellungen dessen was normal ist das
selbstverständlich ist was denkbar auch
ist die ändern sich in unterschiedlichen
geschwindigkeiten
jetzt haben sie gesagt es geht doch oft
dann von der elite aus wie auch frau
richter schon gesagt hat frau am länger
warum hat denn die elite in der schweiz
nicht früher die sache sozusagen
vorangetrieben weil das muss man jetzt
auch mal sagen war es nicht so dass die
gesamten bundesräte und national und
ständeräte früher schon gesagt haben wir
wollen unbedingt das frauenstimmrecht
genau
also das war immer auch wieder ein ganz
bewusster entscheid von der elite sich
gegen dieses frauenstimmrecht
zuzustellen
es gab ja verschiedene vorstöße
parlamentarische es gab diese
frauenstimmrechts märz 1929 die
übergeben wurde
da gibt es ja dieses berühmte zitat das
damalige zuständigen bundesrates als er
das dann seinem nachfolger übergeben hat
er sagte einfach ja dieses dokument zum
frauenstimmrecht das liegt dann in einer
schublade im beach im schreibtisch aus
es wurde wirklich aktiv auch für züge
und zwar von auch der politischen elite
es war aber auch das reisen aus
staatstragende partei hat überhaupt
nicht weitergemacht oder vor lässt
gemacht nicht zuletzt aus angst vor der
konkurrenz dass sich auch ein wichtiger
punkt dass wurde seine bündnispartner
länder konkurrenz katholisch konservativ
damals nicht vor den kopf stoßen sie
diesen bündnispartner verlieren ein
anderes argument was oft auch gebracht
wird ist dass man sagt in vielen ländern
europas waren sozusagen die beiden
weltkriege treiber betreiberinnen des
frauenstimmrechts des traums wahlrechts
dass man gesagt hat naja da kamen
irgendwie dann zu wenig männer nach
hause
die da die viele sind gefallen im krieg
das heißt es gab wirklich eine
notwendigkeit auch dass frauen mit
gestalten konnten in der schweiz nicht
aber da hatten wir nicht so viele
verluste sozusagen und gleichzeitig auch
das argument dass natürlich viele junge
demokratien sich neu konstituieren
weil sie unter druck waren weil die
demokratie so ausgehöhlt war während des
krieges auch das in der schweiz weniger
der fall
genau das ist eine unsitte diese quasi
inwiefern das krieg auch wirklich
wirklich ist den frauen stimmt nicht
dass das irgendwie zu schnelleren
durchsetzung geführt hat in der schweiz
aber tatsächlich so aus erstens war die
die männer waren zum teil auch
christlich geschaffen an der front auch
eingesetzt so der arbeitsplätze frei die
frauen haben die übernommen aber die
männer die geniale wieder zurück und
insofern was kein emanzipations schub
jetzt für die schweizer frauen und im
gegenteil hat sich dann auf der
politischen ebene hat man sich darauf
eigentlich berufen das ja irgendwie so
günstig sind gekommen sind weil wir eine
so gut funktionieren demokratie haben
also dieses selbst wird das in celle
blieb ruth als wiege der demokratie
wurde eigentlich doch was versteckt und
damit auch der ausschluss den frauen aus
dieser demokratie frau richter sie sagen
auch dass diese these dass der krieg
sozusagen der treiber sei des
frauenwahlrechts das sei humbug
ich würde nicht so weit gehen und sagen
das ist humbug war
solche demokratisierungsprozesse finde
unwahrscheinlich kompliziert und was wir
ins seit dem 19 jahrhundert sehen ist
tatsächlich dass kriege oft am ende zu
mehr partizipation führen das sehen wir
auch um 1870 wohnen viele vielen ländern
starke demokratisierungsprozess passiert
und eben sehr stark nach dem ersten
weltkrieg wohl nicht nur in deutschland
sondern auch in vielen anderen ländern
das frauenwahlrecht eingeführt wird also
das spiel eine gewisse rolle
aber was mich daran stört wenn wir
allein den vater als dem krieg als vater
des frauenwahlrechts sehen ist die
vorstellung die frauen bekommen das als
geschenk und sie haben nichts dafür
gemacht und das ist wirklich ganz ganz
falsch das übersieht die große starke
frauenbewegung diese eben um 1900 gab wo
die frauen ganz ganz stark dafür
gekämpft haben in den usa in
großbritannien auch in deutschland gab
es eine sehr sehr starke frauenbewegung
und erstaunlich ist nach dem ersten
weltkrieg dann wie selbstverständlich
das frauenwahlrecht akzeptiert wird ich
hatte als ich angefangen habe die die
zeitungen zu lesen derzeit die
unterlagen habe ich gehofft dass jetzt
alle ganzer staat sind und und erstaunt
sind begeistert sind dass die frauen
wählen aber
das ist was ganz was ganz
selbstverständlich kommt und es hat ganz
viel eben damit zu tun das ist schon
vorher sich viel geändert hat und dass
eben frauen sehr sehr stark sich dafür
eingesetzt haben
sie betonen aber auch in ihren
verschiedenen arbeiten das ist eine
verzerrung ist die idee dass sozusagen
das frauenwahlrecht und überhaupt
demokratie geschichte eine geschichte
des krieges der revolution ist also man
erzählt demokratiegeschichte immer gerne
so mit wehenden fahnen mit geballten
fäusten mit hellebarden einreisende
mauern und so weiter so wird demokratie
gemacht und die haben gerade was die
frauen anbelangt und der kampf der
frauen ist das eine verzerrung der
geschichte der demokratie und führt dazu
dass sie die frauen eigentlich konstant
ausblenden dass sie auch in den
geschichtsbüchern gar nicht erst
vorkommen ja das ist ja wirklich richtig
erstaunlich dass die ganzen großen
demokratiegeschichte die ganzen großen
demokratie theorien das ändert sich
jetzt langsam aber dass die über
jahrzehnte hinweg vollkommen die frauen
ausgeblendet haben manchmal gibt es ein
extra kapitel und einige sagen ganz
explizit einige der großen klassischen
theorien die frauen zählen gar nicht
wirklich weil sie haben gar nicht dafür
gekämpft und die kriegen ist ein
geschenk durch den krieg oder durch
revolution oder was auch immer
aber es gibt jetzt neuere studien
das ist eine amerikanische
politikwissenschaftlerin und die sagt
das problem ist tatsächlich dass wir
demokratiegeschichte nur als
revolutionsgeschichte verstehen nur als
diesen männlichen kampf möglich noch auf
barrikaden von unten aber die frauen die
frauenbewegung haben sich in der zweiten
hälfte des 19 jahrhunderts gegründet
wurden dann am ende des jahrhunderts
stark und laut zum ersten mal wirklich
eine laute politische kraft und die
kämpfe neben in rechtsstaaten die die
allermeisten staaten im nordatlantischen
raum waren einfach rechtsstaaten und da
ist revolution einfach nicht sinnvoll
also wir hatten ganz andere kämpfe und
ich würde auch noch betonen diese
frauenbewegungen hatten bilder die mich
in unsere demokratie geschichte schaffen
wenn wir das anschauen die frauen die
haben lange röcke die haben merkwürdige
hüte an was machen sie sie treffen sich
schreiben petitionen das ist eben
überhaupt nicht dieser mann der auf der
barrikade steht hinter ihm
die welt
und er bringt der welt des heil- und wir
müssen unbedingt unsere demokratie
geschichte erweitern um diese um diese
neuen bilder um diese um diesen neuen
ganz ganz anderen kampf und das ist ja
interessant dass wir trotzdem eigentlich
am allerliebsten diejenigen frauen
erinnern die eben genau in dieses
männliche bild der demokratiegeschichte
passen also diejenigen geben wirklich
mit viel gewalt auf die straße gegangen
sind zum beispiel in großbritannien die
sowjets da gab es schon mehrere
hollywood verfilmungen die sehen ein
bild aus dem film von 2015 mit helena
bonham carter in der hauptrolle ein
der große erfolge gefeiert hat vom
länger sie sagen die arbeit von
schweizer aktivistinnen die wir oft sehr
viel weniger spektakulär und sehr oft
auch ganz stolz konform dass man muss
schon sehen dass ein ganz großer teil
dieser frauenstimme es bewegung das war
ein französischer herkunft ja und dann
muss man einfach sehen die waren sehr
oft ängste künstler auch mit dem frei
sind das waren ehefrauen manchmal auch
töchter von vielleicht einigen
politikern und die kommen aus einem
rahmen aus einem milieu wurden
sozialisiert in diesem bötchen milieu
und ein militantes vorgehen waren
schlichtweg einfach auch wirklich fällt
völlig fremd dann kam aber auch hinzu
dass sie genau wussten wenn ich jetzt
ein bisschen militanter auftreten wird
was in der schweiz relativ schnell als
militant angesehen mit irgendwas zu
machen dass sie dann wiederum von der
gegner und gegnerinnen des frauen stehen
da ist natürlich die familien würden
also das war ein ganz schwieriger
position auch ich möchte da aber schon
auch noch ein haken das was die gerichte
gesagt hat also was sehen wir denn
überhaupt als militant also jetzt als
heutige sich wenn der frauen durch die
staatsmaschine mit einer fackel in der
hand ruhig oder dann ist das für uns
natürlich nicht militant ab diese zeit
und für diese frauen war das ein großer
schritt und sie müssen ja auch mit
sanktionen rechnen also das war wurde
angegriffen solche aktionen
die frau habe für sie ist das ja auch
ganz wichtigen wieder zu betonen
demokratiegeschichte ist auch einfach
nicht nur revolutionär sondern sehr oft
einfach das resultat von kleinen feinen
reformen von einer langsamen arbeit und
sie sagen auch es ist immer auch eine
geschichte der kontinuität ein stück
weit und das frauenwahlrecht 30 ein in
eine geschichte der immer weitergehenden
inklusion
ja genau also es gibt verschiedene dinge
die wir ansprechen das eine ist
natürlich wirklich dass es nicht nur
diese
diese impulse und punktuellen
veränderungen gibt sondern immer auch
die die gesellschaft weniger
spektakulären gesellschaftlichen
entwicklungen und ich glaube dieses
zusammenspiel das war eigentlich in all
diesen inklusions wellen oder epochen
der demokratischen entwicklung wichtig
oder also die historikerinnen kennen
sich da besser aus als ich natürlich
aber wenn wir jetzt denken im team ich
denke zweiten hälfte 19 jahrhundert für
die schweiz die einführung des
allgemeinen männer wahlrechts aussehen
und bürgerliche freiheiten
dann um die jahrhundertwende die
inklusion der tieferen sozialen
schichten arbeiterklasse und dann in 20
jahrhundert sehr klar dieser diese
debatte um die inklusion der frauen in
die demokratie
also es gibt immer wieder und der
länderspezifischen in den usa natürlich
die die sklavenbefreiung und integration
also es gibt immer wieder diese epoche
und prozesse die sehr vielschichtig sind
und was mir auch sehr wichtig scheint
jetzt in diesem zusammenhang wenn wir
sagen nicht überbetonen der
einzelkämpfer unter einzelereignisse
1971 ist natürlich ganz wichtig und
jetzt sagen gedenkt tag aber auch die
einführung der würde nicht nur sagen
dass die einführung des
frauenstimmrechts sondern die
demokratische inklusion der frauen als
vollwertige selbstverständliche subjekte
demokratisches objekte das ist ja ein
ein prozess der nicht nur über die
einführung des passiven wahlrechtes oder
aktiven wahlrechtes geschieht also dass
man ihm seine stimme abgeben darf oder
dass man kandidieren darf sondern das
schließt bürgerrechte mit einschließt
soziale rechte mit ein
das alles bildet ein paket der
demokratischen bürgerschaft
das in einer ich würde sagen epoche die
irgendwie von 19 60 vielleicht bis heute
andauert ist das ein prozess dieser
demokratischen inklusion und ich glaube
wenn man so darüber nachdenkt dann
öffnet das einerseits die augen dafür
dass es nicht nur um das stimmrecht geht
sondern um auch die voraussetzungen
dafür
diese mitsprache überhaupt wahrnehmen zu
können durch soziale rechte bürgerrechte
organisation und zweitens öffnet es die
augen dafür dass diese prozesse eben
nicht abgeschlossen sind das immer
verhandelbar sind dass sie ein
automatismus bei inhalt genau und wir
können es auch heute noch weiter denken
noch mehr inkludieren darauf werden wir
dann später noch einmal zurückkommen
ich würde gerne noch darüber sprechen
dass diese demokratie geschichte wenn
wir auch mit blick auf frauen über
demokratie geschichte sprechen ja immer
auch eine körper geschichte ist und war
auch das ist eine these die sie
vertreten frau richter in ihrem viel
diskutierten buch demokratie eine
deutsche auf faire ist das auch ein ganz
wichtiges moment dass sie sagen
demokratiegeschichte ist eine körper
geschichte und sie erzählen ganz
wunderbar geben die aber auch
schockierend wie das in den usa war also
sozusagen die wahlen bevor die frauen
eben mitbestimmen konnten waren das
veritable saufgelage es wurde es ging um
große gelder die man gewinnen konnte bei
wetten man hat gestochen es gab
korruption man hat sich geschlagen
geprügelt getrunken und das ganze war
schon eher sie sagen ein wallgau die
fast schon genau es wird sogar als
männlicher sports bezeichnet in der in
der wahlforschung und ich kann das nur
unterstreichen was für häuser man gesagt
hat dass eben demokratisierungsprozesse
dass wir da auch die kontinuitäten sehen
müssen und ich denke dass wenn wir
veränderungen von herrschaftswissen
sehen dass wir dann dass das immer
einher geht mit einer veränderung des
körper regimes und in der mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts in den usa das
war eine unwahrscheinliche gewalttätige
gesellschaft die dann auch nicht
zufälligerweise in diesen absolut
grausamen bürgerkrieg gegangen ist und
es war ganz klar dass am wahlort die
frauen nichts zu suchen
hat also das wurde ganz körperlich
inszeniert und das ist überhaupt wichtig
dass im neunzehnten jahrhundert diese
ganzen entwicklung von demokratie
parlamentarismus die wahlen eben auch
sehr sehr stark die rede die öffentliche
rede das was ganz intensiv mit
männlicher körperlichkeit verbunden
die frau hatte eine zu dünne stimme die
kann auf keinen fall in der
öffentlichkeit reden das finden wir auch
schon in vielen religionen verankert und
dass sich das allmählich das ändert sich
sehr sehr stark um 1900 und das ist ja
eine zeit des großen aufbruchs für
frauen und dann würde ich aber auch noch
mal genau das unterstreichen was meine
vorgängerin gesagt hat in der in den
jahren um 1970 sehen wir wieder einen
riesigen shift im körper regime das sich
ganz stark ändert für frauen ist
natürlich ganz zentral dass die pille
auf kommt das kann man überhaupt nicht
unterschätzen männerpolitik hat ja in
den kneipen stattgefunden abends es wird
geraucht gesoffen usw
frauen sind selbstverständlich mit ihren
kindern als so ein zuhause gefunden das
war die vorstellung nicht
zufälligerweise waren die wenigen frauen
die auch in der bundesrepublik weiter
oben mitspielen in aller regel ledige
frauen mit der pille hat die frau das
ganz ganz anders in der hand und mit
einer gewissen zeit versetzung des kommt
dann doch erst einige jahre später sehen
wir dann auch er ist in der
bundesrepublik wie allmählich
beträchtliche anzahl an frauen eben in
die parlamente kommen
es gibt ihnen den ruf aus den usa auch
dass die geschichte oder was kann man
sich von ihnen gelernt habe dass um
19.16 herum erst die wahlen dann verlegt
wurden inoffizielle gebäude vorher war
die stimmabgabe einfach in der kneipe
schon klar dass da keine frau sich rein
vertraute und plötzlich kaum
hygienemaßnahmen auf also man hat
irgendwie den anspruch sich auch
körperlich entsprechend zu präsentieren
die polizei kontrollierte das ganze
geschehen also es ging auch um sichere
wahlen das alles hat es den frauen
einfacher gemacht damit zu tun gibt es
so was vergleichbares auch in der
schweizer demokratie geschichte und
sorgen müsste die frauen hatten
irgendwie auch rein jetzt eben von ihrem
körperlichen auftreten her auch gar
keine möglichkeit mitzumachen
also vielleicht eben noch etwas zudem
sagen was jetzt diskutiert wurde also
ich habe ein bisschen ein unbehagen
diese kontinuität these ja also das
für mich ist das ein bisschen nach
diesem fortschritt narrativ also es hat
mal ein staat gegen demokratie wurde
erfunden
dann war eine gruppe inkludiert und dann
tut sich das immer mehr auf ja aber ich
finde schon man muss schon sehen also
die auch die schweiz die ist konstitutiv
entstanden unter ausschluss von frauen
also die kategorie geschlecht die war
eine kategorie des politischen
ausschlusses jahr und sieht ja nicht
erst im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
irgendwie dieser forderungen laut
geworden sondern die sind schon bei der
französischen demokratie mit orlando
bosch also die hat dort schon
angeprangert dass die allgemeinen
menschenrechte ebel oder bürgerrechte
nicht für alle zählen also ich finde das
lässt sich nicht so innovativ einordnen
das in diese richtung der fahrtrichtung
geht gerne frau richter ich will das ja
unterstreichen also dass das war nicht
damit gemeint dass es eine kontinuität
kontinuierliche geschichte ist ganz im
gegenteil wir sehen diese geschichte
immer wieder ganz ganz brutal
unterbrochen also zum beispiel das
wahlrecht afroamerikaner
aber wir haben das auch in anderen
fällen und und ich denke auch dass es
ganz wichtig ist um gerade auch die
schweizer demokratie zu verstehen dass
alles was mit republik mit schweiz mit
mit demokratie zu tun hat wie parlament
wurde eine intimität mit männlichkeit
verbunden die wir heute in der schwer
nachvollziehen können dass das äußerte
sich dann so was wie das sie war neben
unwahrscheinlich männlich gestaltet
wurden in den usa war das besonders
extrem aber wir sehen das auch in europa
alkohol spielte überall eine rolle aber
in den usa bis zum beispiel dann auch
große gelehrte schriften darüber warum
demokratie besser ist und zwar deswegen
ganz eindeutig weil demokratie männlich
ist dass es gibt ganz explizit
diskussionen darüber demokratie ist
besser weil es männlich ist weil dann
nur leistung zählt in diesem
monarchistischen europa kann ja das
entsetzliche passieren dass plötzlich
eine frau auf den thron kommen also das
finde ich auch ganz ganz wichtig dass
vorstellung von demokratie von
partizipation parlaments dass das ganz
ganz intim mit männlichkeit verbunden
wird und es gibt ja auch die these dass
die schweizer spät dran ist ähnlich wie
frei
kann ich das ja auch relativ spät dran
ist dass diese alten republiken mit
ihren alten demokratischen traditionen
eben besonders intim mit männlichkeit
verbunden sind und sich dann besonders
schwer tun sich von dieser von dieser
form des männlichen republikanismus zu
verabschieden
also ich möchte einerseits natürlich
völlig zustimmen dass es aspekte des der
frauen inklusion der demokratischen
frauen inklusion gibt die ganz
spezifisch sind die nicht so einfach
vergleichbar sind mit anderen inklusions
dynamiken der demokratie und gerade
diese argumentation über die
körperlichkeit körperliche
selbstbestimmung ist sicher ein aspekt
der besonders wichtig ist wenn auch
eigentlich nicht exklusiv dass jetzt die
frage betrifft während die an die
sklavenbefreiung leben denken aber ich
meine wenn wir das uns betrachten ist
das natürlich schon so dass die
demokratie die demokratisierung
fortgeschritten ist in verschiedene
kontinuierlich eigentlich expansiv sich
weiterentwickelt hat
was ich aber unbedingt vermeiden möchten
da bin ich völlig einverstanden mit
ihrem widerspruch frau merkel ist zu
suggerieren dass es so eine natürliche
eine natürliche modernisierung
wertewandel gibt man muss auch warten
und dann wird es immer inklusive und
immer universalistische dem ich sicher
nicht so genau wie wir jetzt diskutieren
jede dieser jede dieser inklusion wurde
erkämpfte stritten wurde bekämpft die
eliten waren auch sicher nicht homogen
progressiven gegenteil sondern das sind
ja immer politische kämpfe aber ich
glaube doch dass es dass es sinnvoll ist
die inklusion der frauen nicht so heraus
zugreifen
einfach weil wir eingestiegen sind mit
dieser frage war die schweiz überhaupt
eine demokratie von 71 das hören wir
immer wieder oder auch bei über 1
studentinnen da kann man nicht von
demokratie sprechen
ich habe volles verständnis dafür aber
das suggeriert dass quasi mit einer
inklusion dann eine schwelle
überschritten ist nach der wir dann von
demokratie sprechen und dann und dann
ist er quasi dass das häkchen gemacht
und so ist es ja nicht also habe man ja
einiges kann dem
der key verständnis das sehr stark auf
die staatsbürgerschaft abstellt werden
haus hat hat demokratische rechte das
ist auch keine selbstverständlichkeit
oder in der demokratietheorie gibt es
starke argumente zu sagen mit sprechen
soll wer betroffen ist und nicht wert
werden passt hat vielleicht ist ja auch
ein bisschen die frage worauf wir das
augenmerk legen und ich hatte sie auch
so verstanden frauen dinge dass sie auch
sagen wollten
moment mal das war auch nicht einfach so
eine schöne eben kontinuität sondern in
der schweiz waren die frauen noch einmal
ganz anders betroffen und geforderten
sie haben erwähnt die französische
philosophin die schon ganz früh gekämpft
hat und gesagt hat es gibt so was wie
menschenrechte dass sie nicht männer
rechte das sind menschenrechte
dazu gehören demokratische rechte und
dann würde mich schon noch einmal
interessieren es gibt ja sehr viel
wissen mittlerweile dazu dass es viele
männer gab die in der schweiz also
politiker die in der schweiz ab den 60er
jahren gesagt haben wir haben ein
problem wir werden langsam zum gespött
im ausland weil wir sollten ja auch die
europäische menschenrechtskonvention
ratifizieren
das passt eben nicht zueinander was
machen wir jetzt und da gab es aber auch
viele politiker die gesagt haben
na ja wir gucken dass es da eine
ausnahmeklausel gab warum was ich würde
schon gerne noch einmal verstehen warum
bei allem lob für die schweiz warum
hatten denn die schweizer männer so ein
problem mit uns frauen ja da gibt es
verschiedene ansätze ich denke wir
müssen uns überlegen wo und was jetzt
eigentlich in der politik ja es geht um
macht und diese macht die die extra die
nicht einfach also wenn jetzt die hälfte
muss plötzlich auch an der macht
beteiligen darf da werden die gremien
der politik als der bundesrat hat da
nicht wirklich viel zeit setzte also es
geht hier um einen verteilungskampf auch
und ich denke das lässt sich einfach
ganz banal lässt sich auf diesen punkt
und es geht ihr um verteidigung der
macht und die will ich geteilt
also ich bin völlig einverstanden
es geht also all diese all diese
vorwände und argumente
also zu dünnen stimme und so weiter ich
meine es ging letztlich herum natürlich
zu verhindern dass diese das dass diese
sozialen gruppen mit sprechen und die
dass die frauen mit spreche aber auch
weil es eben einen unterschied macht
also man nennt das deskriptive
repräsentation ob die menschen wirklich
vertreten sind quasi die sozialen
gruppen vertreten sind in der
politischen mitbestimmung und die macht
einen unterschied ich gebe ihnen ein
beispiel ein besonders prägnantes
beispiel nicht das einzige
diese revision des rechtes mitte der
80er jahre in der schweiz in der die
frau gleich gestellt wurde in der ehe
nicht vollständig aber das war der
zentrale schritt der gleichstellung der
frau in der ehe diese reform wurde wegen
der frauen angenommen
die männer haben sie abgelehnt in der
abstimmung die beiden frauen gab es eine
große mehrheit über 60 und obwohl die
frauen damals noch weniger partizipiert
haben dass die männer hat diese große
unterschied dazu geführt dass die
vorlage angenommen wurde also es gibt
das als beispiel und auch systematisch
forschung wissen wir auch wenn frauen
wenn es mehr frauen hat im parlament
wenn mehr frauen partizipieren kommen
andere themen stärker auf die agenda
werden andere entscheidungen gefällt
also es geht um gestaltungsmacht und das
verändert auch die voraussetzung für
weitere politik es geht spielen immer
strategische argumente mit dieser kommt
wirklich gehört zu werden und mitmachen
zu können ganz real der war 1971
eigentlich noch gar nicht abgeschlossen
zwar hatten die frauen dann in der
schweiz auch endlich das wahl- und
stimmrecht aber sie frauen länger sagen
immer wieder die geschichte war aus
nicht abgeschlossen sondern die kommt
eigentlich erst zu einem ersten großen
wirklichen abschluss mit dem brunner
skandal und wir schauen kurz zurück
worum es sich dabei handelt das war 1993
erst hier ist den brunnen wird zum
gefundenen fressen für die medien ihre
einfache herkunft ihrer
patchwork-familie ihre spontane art
gegen reichlich stoff ein anonymer brief
kündigt enthüllungen und ein nacktfoto
an die schlammschlacht schwappt ins
bundes
in session vorgespräch ziehen einige
politiker hemmungslose christian brunner
her dreht der zubau tag hunderte von
frauen reisen nach bern fast bundeshaus
eine stunde später dann der erste
wahlgang nach dem zweiten wahlgang steht
fest dass die offizielle sp kandidaten
tatsächlich gewählt ist gewählt ist der
gewählte bundesrat hatte fordert für sie
die fraktion eine woche bedenkzeit in
der hoffnung die genossen hinter sich zu
scharen
die nicht gewählte bundesrat kandidatin
muss drei und trost spenden
parlamentarierinnen aller couleur sind
so maßlos enttäuscht wie die frauen
draußen auf dem platz mit polizeigewalt
wird eine mahnwache aufgelöst ein
peinlicher wahlakt endet in tränengas
das rennen bleibt offen
die wahlstrategen der sp suchen einen
ausweg mattek-sands verzicht bewegen und
grüne zur wahl verhelfen können
montagmittag sitzungsunterbrechung viel
wird bekannt france ihm at hat die
fraktion massiv unter druck gesetzt
beharrt sie auf der einer kandidatur
brunner will er am mittwoch nicht
verzichten auf die nötigung reagiert die
spd führung mit einer doppelkandidatur
neben der dem parlament wenig bekannten
smith präsidentin brunner steigt die
noch weit weniger bekannte gewerkschafts
und sekretärin ruth dreifuss als
zwillingsschwester ins rennen zehnter
märz weiter wahltag
nur ein fernsehteam darf beobachten wie
und dreyfus ihrer wahl erlebt zusammen
mit lilian uchtenhagen die zehn jahre
zuvor bei einer bundesratswahl
gescheitert war
[Musik]
noch ist christian brunner im rennen
doch hat sie im parlament keine chance
nun gibt christian brunner ihre
verzichtserklärung ab
doch noch vivo im nationalratssaal das
resultat verkündet wird weiß wo dreyfus
dass sie gewählt ist
ich fürchte dass es in zwei gründe sind
und weiter sind unannehmbar
ich glaube dass äußerliche vielleicht
ich beruhige die leute weil ich ein
wenig besser aussehe
und das ist nur weil ich mich darum
nicht interessiere wie ich aussehe
und das zweite ist vielleicht weil ich
entspreche genau was man von einer frau
in der politik erwartet ledig keine
familie so etwas zwischen mann und frau
das alles geopfert hat und dadurch
vielleicht eine anspruch hatte auf
anerkennung und beides ist für mich sehr
schockierend
ja das war diese drohne skandal von 1993
aus jedem christian brunner nicht
gewählt wurde nun das war eigentlich
nicht das einzige mal dass eine frau
nicht gewählt wurde was sie hier oben
gehabt haben es wirklich ein absoluter
skandal und ein wendepunkt ich würde
nicht gerade deshalb das hat den
ausschluss der frauen irgendwie jetzt
beendet zumindest auf bundesebene
bundesrat ebene hat es beendet aber
nicht generell aber es war ein ganz
massiver einbruch in diese geschichte in
dieser lange tradition des politischen
ausschluss von frauen aus eben wieder
mit 19 71 gesprochen es dann kamen
frauen zum politischen technik hat dann
wurde hier auch wieder nachhaken erwähnt
und in dieser reihe kommt dann eben auch
diese christian brunner und anders als
zuvor wurde das heft nicht mehr
akzeptiert also plötzlich war es war der
eine woche also in diesem 1
bis zum 2 und diese woche gingen
zehntausende von menschen auf die straße
protestierten gegen diese bundesrat sei
es gab ja noch nie in der geschichte
dieser zahlen und hat dann letztlich
eigentlich bewegt dass er tatsächlich
eine frau bundesrätin boden nämlich ruth
dreifuss und wir sehen einfach in diesem
moment dass da ein zwei welten
aufeinander braten also die befördert
der alten ordnung der atem patrick
anordnung wonach die politische macht
bei den männern liegt und die
gesellschaft eigentlich die jetzt um mit
gleichstellungs bemühung natürlich an
einem ganz anderen punkt war auch gerade
von der neuen frauenbewegung und jetzt
auch eben dieser außerdem verwahrte die
mussten spätestens jetzt einsehen dass
es so nicht mehr geht also wir können
nicht mehr sukzessive diese frauen
ausschließen aus dem politisch ja genau
also so einfach nicht mehr machbar ist
frau richter für sich das ja auch ein
wichtiger punkt immer wieder zu betonen
niemandem darf wahl oder stimmrecht zu
geben ist noch nicht gleichbedeutend mit
einer wirklich funktionierenden
demokratie sondern es gibt andere formen
von ausschluss mechanismen ist insofern
diese geschichte der schweiz auch
typisch also ich hatte haben anfang
gesagt dass das man voller bewunderung
auf die schweiz schauen dass es auf
jeden fall richtig aber ich wollte damit
überhaupt nicht das relativieren dass
das natürlich ein skandal war dass dies
das frauenwahlrecht zu spät kam
also das ist unwahrscheinlich wichtig
dass das frauenwahlrecht kommt ein
wichtiger grund für die verzögerung des
frauenwahlrechts war ja immer wieder
dass man gesagt es gibt auch wichtigeres
und ganz ganz wichtiges argument um
gottes willen warum streit um das
frauenwahlrecht wir haben doch viel
wichtigere dinge jetzt zu tun
also das sind alles soldo argumente
denke ich aber wir sehen natürlich auch
regimes wo frauen das wahlrecht haben wo
aber die ganzen wahlen hochproblematisch
sind wir hatten das lange zeit in staatz
sozialistischen regimes neben im stall
inis muss gibt es schon ziemlich früh in
frauenwahlrecht aber wenn wenn es im
prinzip dann überhaupt nicht darum geht
dass das tatsächlich das volk
mitbestimmen kann dann ist natürlich
auch das frauenwahlrecht ich sehr viel
wert diese diese wahlen sind trotzdem
sehr sehr wichtig um hochinteressant ist
ein interessanter performanz der
unterwerfung aber da sehen wir das
einfach nur
der akt des frauenstimmrechts wenn es
sich gar nicht um eine form der
herrschaft handelt wo diese wahlen
tatsächlich relevant sind und dass dann
das frauenwahlrecht auch natürlichen
geringeren wert hat aber in demokratien
ist das natürlich oder in rechtsstaaten
wie wir sie um 1910 ist das natürlich
ganz ganz wichtig das frauenwahlrecht
haben sie haben ja auch vorhin gespräch
schon einmal gesagt demokratische rechte
erschöpfen sich nicht einfach in
mitsprache also eben eine wahl oder
stimmrecht zu haben sondern es geht um
ein großes paket auch in sozialer rechte
würden sie denn so weit gehen und sagen
na ja die frauen hatten 19 71 zwar einen
wahl und stimmrecht aber sie hatten noch
nicht alle sozialen rechte ja auf jeden
fall unbedingt also ich denke das ist
sehr wichtig so nachzudenken über
demokratische über demokratische
mitbestimmung als 1 1 ein paket an
voraussetzungen die es braucht um diese
mitsprache wahrzunehmen
traurig trat event es braucht die
institutionen damit diese stimme
überhaupt ausgeübt werden kann um zählt
bei den frauen war das damals mit dem
proporz wales sturm gegeben aber ein
gutes beispiel sozusagen der schweiz hat
mir die arbeiter schon vor 1919 das
stimmrecht aber erst mit der einführung
des proporz wahlrechtes hat es wirklich
eine veränderung gebracht haben sie
wirklich politische macht erhalten was
ihn zur institutionellen voraussetzungen
die zeigen es reicht nicht das aktive
wahlrecht einfach es braucht die
voraussetzung dass dann auch das auch
zählt und eben ich würde noch weiter
gehen ich würde sagen demokratische
inklusion bedient nicht nur politische
rechte sondern auch soziale rechte
ansprüche und zwar aus zwei gründen also
dass ich möchte als beispiel vielleicht
ein beispiel geben als ein bereich den
ich aus der eigenen arbeit gut kenne die
rentenpolitik in der schweiz scheint
jetzt relativ weit weg von dem was wir
hier diskutieren ist es aber nicht
in den 90er frühen 2000er jahren wurden
die altersrenten ansprüche für die
frauen massiv verbessert in der schweiz
dadurch dass beiträge gesplittet worden
dass sie im fall einer scheidung besser
gestellt wurden und auch dadurch dass
betreuungs gutschriften angerechnet
wurden und dass teilzeitarbeit besser
für sie und das ist für die frau
die normalität in der schweiz das ist
nicht eine art typische de wieandts von
der norm sondern das ist eine ganz
normale frauen biografie in der schweiz
teilzeitarbeit weniger verdienen als der
mann vielleicht irgendwann eine
scheidung und dann war was ist dann
und diese diese ganze einbettung ist
nicht nur wichtig weil sie natürlich die
materielle situation der frauen
verbessert und das ist auch eine
voraussetzung für mitsprache aktive
politische partizipation dass man nicht
ständig nur quasi über materielles
nachdenken muss aber sie ist auch
deshalb wichtig weil diese sozialen
rechte die auffassung verändern dessen
was normal ist was ein ganz normaler
bürger eine ganz normale bürgerin für
ein leben hat also ein mit ein ein
berechtigtes mitglied dieses themas war
was das was man sich darunter vorstellt
und dazu gehört eben nicht nur das
wahlrecht sondern es gehört diese ganze
anerkennung der verschiedenen
lebensrealitäten diese branche liegt im
historischen museum in bern da gibt es
eine sonderausstellung das
frauenwahlrecht die sie kuratieren
fabian am länger
die sp macht im moment so kleine
branchen bildet sie nach das war
eigentlich das symbol nach diesem bruna
skandal für die gleichberechtigung für
diesen kampf der frauen die vorher frau
bruna und frau drives haben beide so
eine branche getragen an diesem wahltag
was würden sie denn sagen diese sonne
steht die jetzt wirklich auch für etwas
was sie erreicht haben wir die sagen wir
sind jetzt tatsächlich so in dieser art
und weise ließ frau sah man gesagt hat
politisch voll integriert wir frauen
oder ist noch immer ein langer weg zu
gehen ja das glas halb voll oder halb
leer am wissen die frage also man darf
sicherlich nicht übersehen dass wirklich
ganz viele fortschritte jetzt hier
erreicht worden politischer art abnehmen
auch die sozialen rechte ist unglaublich
wichtig oder unter wurde eigentlich in
kurzer zeit doch muss man schon auch
sehen relativ also sehr viel erreicht ja
aber dennoch sind sie jetzt sind wir
jetzt gleich berechtigt da müssen wir
schon nur die statistiken anschauen
sehen wie es also bleiben wir beim feld
der politik nein natürlich nicht
zwar 2014 kraft diese so genannten
frauen waren ja da wurde der
frauenanteil in den parlamenten ja
stände und nationalrat massiv erhöht
aber auch im nationalrat zu hoch wie
noch nie 42 prozent auf 10 8% und wenn
wir den ständerat anschauen dann sind
das immer noch drei männer und eine frau
und man darf auch also ich finde auch
dass man nur so kurzfristig
zurückschauen das sie soll kinder da
schaue ich halte den etappen an und dann
sehen wir auch immer wieder dass nichts
vor einem rückfall gefeit ist also diese
anteile gehen auch wieder zurück und
dann werden sie manchmal auch ein
bisschen was wenn man nur die zahlen
anschaut dass sie die frage ist ja dann
auch wo sitzen die frauen also wo
passiert wirklich die macht sind sie
dort an diesen kommission an diesen
stellen und da ist nach wie vor vieles
zu tun
frau richter wie blicken sie auf die
frage der gleichstellung bereits in mir
denn politisch wenn sie jetzt mal irland
betrachten
deutschland also ich kann mich dafür nur
anschließen ich würde auch zunächst
betonen dass wir wahnsinnig viel
erreicht haben das sollten wir auf
keinen fall vergessen dass wir drei
jetzt hier sitzen dass wir drei
wissenschaftlerinnen sind die gäste dass
wir in deutschland die bundeskanzlerin
haben dass wir einfach vor 30 jahren
noch unvorstellbar gewesen oder auch
solche dinge wie das inzwischen eine
große mehrheit für schwulen ehe ist also
wenn wir jetzt das blickt er ist der der
geschlechter weiter dass das hat sich
doch wahnsinnig viel verändert hat sich
ganz ganz viel getan
und dennoch sollten wir nicht übersehen
dass noch ein weiter weg zu gehen ist
gerade wenn es um ganz konkrete
machtpositionen geht
bundestag bei uns haben wir gesehen dass
es dass der anteil der frauen sogar
zurückgegangen ist wir sind nur bei
einem drittel an abgeordneten also da
gibt es noch sehr viel zu tun denke ich
und dann sprechen wir doch mal darüber
was ist dennoch zu tun gebe ihre
publikation zum thema heißt im vorzimmer
der macht das finde ich so ein schönes
bild wer steht denn heute im vorzimmer
der macht wer kämpft heute um inklusion
frau häusern an
ja ich denke also wenn es jetzt eine
große bewegung geben oder wie die herr
wie die frauenbewegung oder die
arbeiterbewegung dann dann dann würden
wir sie sehen und ich denke so so akut
ist die die bewegung zur ausdehnung der
politischen rechte moment nicht aber ich
denke die fragen die uns die uns
beschäftigen jetzt bezüglich der
demokratischen rechte in der schweiz
die sind natürlich schon auf dem tisch
in der schweiz ist es so dass in
diversen gemeinden frauen in der
westschweiz auch in zwei kantonen in der
westschweiz auch personen oder einwohner
einwohnerinnen ohne staatsbürgerschaft
mitbestimmen dürfen abstimmen dürfen
und das ist mit sicherheit ein thema
dass das weiter auf der agenda bleiben
wird ich sehe das auch in einer
kontinuität von 30 40 50 jahren in der
diese diskussion geführt werden wird
aber dies natürlich ganz ganz virulent
quasi wer soll denn mitbestimmen
gerade in einem land wie der schweiz
oder der anteil der menschen ohne
staatsbürgerschaft über ein viertel
liegt also sehr viele menschen sind die
von den politischen entscheidungen
betroffen sind sie aber nicht
mitgestalten sich aus sagen wir haben
einen so hohen ausländeranteil weil wir
sehr spät erst ein bürgern das muss man
immer im verhältnis natürlich auch noch
betonen rauch ja nicht nur aber auch
also das ist nicht nicht der
entscheidende faktor
es ist auch aber aber es ändert nichts
daran dass das quasi die frage ist wie
auf welcher auf welchen kriterien
basieren wir die entscheidung ob jemand
mitsprechen love oder nicht die das hat
auch zwei seiten oder wenn wir jetzt
sagen wir wir wechseln dazu dass
mit sprechen die betroffenen sind würde
das heißen dass der auslandschweizer
dann nicht mehr mit sprechen sondern
eben die leute die hier wohnen also es
ist nicht einfach immer nur expansiv es
ist ein anderes prinzip in der schweiz
im moment diskutieren wir auch über die
absenkung des stimmrechtsalters oder 91
wurde von 20 auf 18 gesetzt im moment
gibt es bestrebungen auf 16
herunterzugehen unter anderen wird
argumentiert um den um den
jugendbewegungen mehr stimme zu geben
die jungen menschen werden heute mit
anderen themen politisiert aus als die
älter als wir politisiert worden oder
die älteren corden politisiert wurden
und diesen themen mehr gewicht zu geben
als das sind prozesse die weiter laufen
und die auch an gewiss noch gewinnen
werden
und ich denke auch dort ist es wichtig
zu sehen dass das sind auch machtfragen
oder das geht da es geht um um
machtverteilung und macht justierungen
genau vielleicht um den punkt noch
einmal aufzunehmen ich weiß nicht ob das
ganz deutlich wurde das ja wirklich
interessant zu sagen na ja eine
möglichkeit die frage zu beantworten wer
ist dieses wir das hier bestimmt ist zu
sagen na ja alle diejenigen die eben
diesen regeln unterworfen sind und
deswegen haben sie gerade gesagt
auslandschweizer also personen die mit
schweizer pass im ausland wohnen die
sind ja dann den regeln dieses landes
unterworfen und nicht den schweizer
regen also müsste man die aus quasi
ausgrenzen das ist ja schon sehr
interessant sein wie wir damit umgehen
mich hat sehr überrascht in der
vorbereitung auf diese sendung wie oft
das eigentlich schon gemacht worden ist
im laufe der demokratiegeschichte dass
man eben nicht nur frauen und sklaven
zum beispiel ausgesondert hat sondern
eben auch ein personen indigene
bevölkerung zum beispiel das kann man
bei charly siegl nachlesen in diesem
frauen artlas ich nenne ein paar
beispiele
australien führte 1902 der frauen
baurecht ein aborigines männer wie
frauen waren ausgeschlossen bis 1962
oder kanada ist die frauen ab 19 18
mitbestimmen die indigene bevölkerung
aber erst ab 1960 stimmberechtigt noch
extremer südafrika weise
südafrikanerinnen also frauen ab 19 30
in die stämme
menschen erst 1984 schwarze menschen
erst ab 1994 das zeigt eigentlich die
ethnie ist war es noch ein stärkeres
explosions merkmal ist das geschlecht
richter also das ist tatsächlich würde
dem thema ganz ganz wichtig und das
finde ich total gut dass sie darauf noch
zu sprechen kommen man hatte für diesen
begriff der internationalität also es
geht nicht nur darum um geschlecht
sondern wir müssen immer die anderen
faktoren mit bedenken genau diät mir das
alte ist auch ganz wichtig in den usa
beispielsweise ist es total wichtig und
gut wenn du ein junger mann bis dem 19
jahrhundert weil dann bist du einfach
stärke kann sich besser durchsetzen
in europäischen ländern
kontinentaleuropäischen ländern vor
allem ist es ihr besser wenn man älter
ist und es ist was ganz ganz anderes ob
du nur weiße frau ist von einem
unerhörten klasse oder eben eine arme
frau von der unteren klasse und gesehen
dass zum beispiel auch in der frauen
bewegen das ist eine große rolle spielt
durchaus auch problematisch es wird
immer wieder ein anschlag gebracht in
den usa beispielsweise warum dürfen die
schwarzen männer wählen und wir frauen
nichts also da gibt es durchaus dieses
rassistische argument überhaupt nicht
bei allen aber bei einem teil der
frauenbewegung oder wir sehen bei
rassist innen und kolonial
vertreterinnen im deutschen reich aber
auch in großbritannien die für sich in
den kolonien das wahlrecht einfordern
die sagen wir spielen hier als weiße
zivilisation so eine wichtige rolle
ihr müsst uns deswegen das wahlrecht
geben also diese geschichte ist
keineswegs wie jede geschichte sozusagen
dir eine geschichte für die für für den
reinen kampf sondern demokratie hat
immer ganz ganz viele wussten und viele
der wurzeln sind problematisch und dazu
gehört auch immer wieder wie merkwürdig
klasse und rasse und die verschiedenen
bereiche ineinander hinein spielen und
eben oft auch gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden ist es eine erfahrung die sie
teilen dieses gegeneinander ausspielen
und vielleicht auch die anschlussfrage
was kann man denn lernen sozusagen aus
der geschichte der geschlechterforschung
mit blick jetzt auf die inklusion eines
breiteren diversity begriffes sag ich
jetzt mal also eben mit blick auf
menschen anderer ethnien man könnte auch
sagen zb menschen mit einer behinderung
die man stärken
addieren könnten demokratische prozesse
wird sehr schwierig die frage was kann
man lernen irgendwie also weil sind ja
schon auch wieder viele diskussionen
auch ich glaube dass es einfach zeigt
sich diese diese grundsätzliche frage
wird ist das der demos also wer bekommt
die rechte und dass das sind in
verschiedenen diskussionen die laufen um
sie auch immer wieder historische
natürlich irgendwo situiert sind
interessant was man lernen kann ich viel
zu schwierig so schwierige frage was
kann man aus der geschichte lernen so
man kann einfach vielleicht sagen wenn
man in die in die vergangenheit schaut
auch die vielen gruppen die
ausgeschlossen wurden ja also außerdem
können wir leben um die vergangen um die
jetzt die gegend war zu verstehen und
damit die zukunft zu gestalten so
vielleicht was ich vielleicht anderen
wollte mit dieser frage ist es da wir
haben anfangs ein spieler diesen mann
der gesagt hat wenn die frauen
mitbestimmen können dann sind wir männer
niemand mehr und wir sehen ja jetzt in
rechtspopulistischen regierungskreisen
anderen ländern sehr stark dass man
dieses wir wieder begrenzen will man
möchte möglichst gerne jetzt nicht die
frauen wieder ausschließen dass ich
gleich zu schwierig aber wirklich dafür
sorgen dass die nationen rein und klar
und begrenzt bleibt was ist da das motiv
geht das in das gleiche rein wir sind
niemand mehr wenn die auch mitbestimmen
dürfen oder was treibt denn diese kräfte
seine eine große schwierige frage was
wir wissen und das geht in die richtung
die
die sie ansprechen ist das ein ganz
starkes motiv für rechts nationales
wählen ist ein gefühl relative
deprivation relative deprivation
bedeutet man denkt man kommt zu kurz man
wird zu wenig beachtet zu wenig
wertgeschätzt und das geht natürlich in
diese richtung oder die idee man muss
das quasi verteidigen man muss die
errungenschaften auch nicht nur
privilegien auch errungenschaften
erfolge den wohlfahrtsstaat und so
weiter muss man verteidigen vor
entwicklungen die ihn gefährden könnten
das ist sicher eine aber grundsätzlich
glaube ich also diese diese der
zielkonflikte oder auch der
internationalität die hier die gerüchte
angesprochen
die sind sehr wichtig in den letzten 20
30 jahren aber hat es schon in europa
eine eine konflikt dimension entwickelt
die genau um diese frage kreist wer ist
dass wir wer ist dieser demos und dieser
konflikt ist so eine übergreifende
konflikt dimension geworden die an an
der eben mehrere dieser themen
besprochen werden also es ist kein
zufall dass die inklusion von frauen
zugewanderten und anderen minderheiten
entlang dieser gleichen konfliktlinie
verläuft weil es der gleiche
unterliegende konflikt ist zwischen
einer position die sagt wir müssen
bewahren wir müssen diese gemeinschaft
dergleichen
diese errungenschaften bewahren das
erreichte nicht gefährden auch sozusagen
und einer anderen position der
gegenposition die demokratien als
offenes emanzipatorisches projekt
versteht die den anspruch hat immer
weitere immer breitere kreise der
menschen an dieser teilhabe in diese
teilhabe zu integrieren und und bislang
ist das der große politische konflikt
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert frau
richter vielleicht zum schluss denn für
sie dieser demers wer ist dieses volk
das diese demokratie macht wer gehört
dazu wer nicht das ist eine der
interessantesten fragen in der
demokratie geschichte und das ändert
sich natürlich im laufe der geschichte
immer stärker
ich bin nicht ganz überzeugte europäerin
und ich sehe einerseits das nation
wahnsinnig wichtig ist gerade auch im
prozess der demokratisierung auch nation
ist übrigens was ganz ganz eng mit
männlichkeit verbunden wird und wir
mussten erst eine neue vorstellung von
nation entwickeln um frauen integrieren
zu können aber nation ist tatsächlich
eine ganz große gleich macherin
und für mich ist jetzt eine interessante
frage können wir den begriff von nation
den oder müssen wir über nationen
hinausgehen um etwas wie eine
europäische eine stärkere europäische
inklusion hinzubekommen also das wäre
für mich eine ganz wichtige frage
vielen dank ja wir sehen demokratie ist
ein offener prozess ein offenes projekt
auch wir sind mittendrin in der
diskussion ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch danke frau
richter dass sie von berlin zu uns
gekommen sind
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich frau
anleger frau häusermann dass sie hierher
gekommen sind
ja wer zum thema weiter lesen wir
verlosen dieses buch hier signiert von
unseren gästen im studio und diese
beiden bücher von hedwig richter auch
mit einer mail an philosophie save.tv
sind sie bei der verlosung dabei
eine warme empfehlung auch für den
großartigen film die göttliche ordnung
der den kampf der schweizerinnen für das
frauenstimmrecht nacherzählt sie sehen
ihn jetzt in unserer mediathek nächste
woche spricht mein kollege wolfram
eilenberger mit der philosophin thea
dorn über die frage was allein sein von
einsamkeit unterscheidet und jetzt
gleich treffen sie in der sternstunde
kunst auf den schriftsteller friedrich
glauser viele jahre verbrachte in der
psychiatrischen klinik münsingen aus der
er mit seiner großen liebe einer
psychiatrie pflegerin türmte heute wäre
ja 125 jahre alt geworden und kann in
vielen gleich jetzt wiederentdeckt
werden
danke für ihr interesse eine gute zeit
und gewalt
[Musik]